d'origine bosniaque ou russes de couleur
rose ou orange
la tomate se décline sous de multiples
variétés pour fêter ses 10 ans
l'association dédale l'âme est à
l'honneur avec l'aide des passionnés de
la plantation du jardin collectif de la
verrière
je suis venu pour échanger avec les
autres pour échanger au niveau des
graines ou les tomates les produits mais
aussi échanger des idées
il ya des expériences diverses et
variées on apprend toujours
la star de la journée a de quoi rougir
tous parlent d'elle et la décortique
pour la découvrir dans ses moindres
détails
il essaie de repartir avec quelques
graines des tomates qui nous plaisent et
de rencontrer ceux qui les ont élevés
c'était matelas et qui vous les offre
l'occasion d'échanger de précieux
conseils notamment pour récupérer ces
fameuses graines de femmes watteo moitié
vinaigre genre 1 et je laisse tremper
toi moi je vais juste cet échange autour
de la tomate n'est qu'un exemple des
actions de l'association de la
co-organisation de festivals alternatiba
à la verrière à la création d'une amap
attrape les membres ont rappelé
l'étendue de leur réussite en disant
nous avons toujours cherché à soutenir
les initiatives positives à créer un
réseau de confiance sur le territoire et
à faire collectif avec toutes les bonnes
volontés prêtes à s'engager pour des
alternatives éthiques
dix années qui ne demande qu'à être
poursuivis prochain rendez vous le 10
novembre pour les ripailles des repas
débat sur le thème des solidarités à
maurepas